text-to-speech API can be used to  convert text into natural sounding audio  let's see how to use text-to-speech with  c-sharp first make sure the API is  enabled in your project and a service I  can exist to make API calls both are  explained in the collab in the video  notes in cloud shell let's create a  simple dotnet console app and add  text-to-speech API nougat package to the  project open the online code editor and  navigate to program dot C s we will  convert a piece of text to speech  reference to text to speech API library  create a text to speech client specify  the text we want to convert specify  voice selection parameters and use mp3  as the audio format finally call  synthesized speech on the input and save  the result to an mp3 file  let's run the app there you go you just  created speech from text using  text-to-speech API you can download and  listen to mp3 file if you like